and congratulations on the victory
against chakri are a good start of the
day actually yeah better than yesterday
but it's still a few more games today
the place
that's for sure but it doesn't happen
that often to create such a great attack
against shakira who is famous to be one
of the most active players in the world
how was it today
yeah i think the structure just really
favors why it is
uh it is nice if i thought post from my
knight and his bishop on b7
probably remains
passive throughout the game and yeah it
was
i think was quite unfortunate decision
for him to shuffle his queen to a8 so
basically queen didn't take any part in
the in into the game so i think it's
i mean anyway it should be better but
when i saw this bishop g6 i was like
quite uh
you know
quite excited so
it's just for an sad and queen g3
hopefully it's
uh you know as good as it uh as it
actually seems to be but yeah if not
then then and whatever then okay i
tricked him yeah there was many times
you could push g4 in this game but you
were trying to you're not doing this
move
did you consider it at any moment yeah
obviously at every moment but the
problem that if i played g4 after he
played h5 it's some kind of an issue
that he takes and gets e4 outpost for
his knight so still is quite nice for me
but i wasn't sure if i want this and uh
to give him counter play
and somehow combine movie freedom of g4
would be an ideal scenario for me but
i didn't see if
i could do this but
yeah i mean i'm still
you know
still studying uh
catalan type of positions so it's a
very nice experience
yeah for sure and how do you feel
yourself here in saint louis
well with every next day after i arrived
uk it was quite quite quite quite a
journey like 30 hours
i would say yeah
so i know it takes some time to recover
and uh
yeah overall i think
it would be even better to you know
arrive here like do this earlier but
yeah hopefully i'll
yeah
my schedule will
be more or less normal closer let's say
to the classical part for sure thank you
so much and all the best of luck in the
next round thank you
[Music]